so there's this cool story this is not a
YC startup although it maybe should have
been cool story we're basically in
Portland you know right now with
coronavirus everybody's getting
deliveries right and so I have a friend
who runs a company called farmstead and
they do grocery delivery they've been
doing this for you know two years now
and they all they all farm set does is
they deliver you know your staple foods
milk eggs bread stuff you need
repeatedly and you don't need you know
go to the grocery store every time you
run out of milk kind of sucks so they
just delivered to your door and so
they're like a version of instacart
that's just focused on the staples okay
now and also you know what a key
difference
instacart goes to the grocery store and
buy stuff and marks it up these guys are
the grocery stores so they just have a
they buy wholesale and they sell retail
so they don't mark it up they actually
get good prices okay
good startup they are exploding 20 X 30
X oversubscribed on demand right now
because everybody is ordering food in
because of coronavirus right so
everyone's getting to try this like
delivery thing they're sort of forced to
do delivery for the first time and what
they calling end those guys are on
farmstead oh not farm theory okay
farmstead okay farmstead yeah this is my
buddy's company I he listens the podcast
sometime so shout-out if he's listening
so cool name love the name
yeah great name great brand it looks
good and the product is good so I
actually like it a lot now one problem
that they're having and that every
delivery company is having right now is
that they're short on drivers are short
on delivery people they have too much
demand and not enough ability to fulfill
so this company in Portland started
hiring out-of-work people from the
coronavirus now what what industry was
been affected by the strip clubs
nobody's going to strip clubs right now
during coronavirus so they hired the
strippers to do delivery and so they got
a bunch of PR from there shaking horary
I gotta find out which company it was I
don't know if it was door - or whatever
I don't even know if the company really
did this or the strippers just started
signing for this that's like oh we got
to make money so what are we gonna do I
guess we should become you know delivery
people right now for the I see it I see
it which do you know which company it is
that they're delivering for business
he jokingly calls it Boober eats so it
all started as a joke with lucky devil
lounge one of his clubs and no one was
coming in and they go we need to do like
uber for weed delivery or Luber for sex
lube delivery and I was like let's do
Boober which is topless girl picks you
up and takes you to a strip club and so
anyway that's the joke is that it's uh I
don't think it's real it but it did get
PR yeah did get PR I think I think I did
read that they were like the gig workers
are basically shifting from one to
another right if you can't if the demand
has gone down and this area's gone up
and delivery and then more people are
becoming delivery drivers and cerebus I
thought that was interesting there's
another one at Quarry meals for 4-inch
heels meals and 6-inch heels well I
don't know if it's smart to create your
own delivery company but I do know if
you're afraid you got to work right now
you know you girls gotta eat got to do
something
[Music]